let's say I wanted to figure out what
negative 2 plus negative 4 is equal to
there are a bunch of ways of thinking
about them but what we're going to do in
this video is think about it using
something called integer chips so with
integer gips if I have a chip that look
like that looks like this a positive
sign with a circle around of it around
it that is equal to a positive one and
if I have a negative sign with the
circle around it that's a negative
integer chip and that's equal to
negative one and of course if I have
exactly one positive integer chip and
one negative integer integer chip well
then they're going to cancel out because
positive 1 plus negative 1 is of course
equal to zero so let's use that to
figure out this and several other
problems so negative two how can I
represent that with integer chips well
that's going to be two of these negative
integer chips so negative 1 and then
negative 2 and then negative 4 is going
to be four of these negative integer
chips so negative one negative 2
negative 3 and negative 4. so now how
many total negative integer chips do I
have I have one two three four five six
so that's going to be six negative
integer chips or negative six let's do
another example
let's say I now have positive 7 plus
negative 6. how can I represent this
with integer chips pause this video and
think about it
well positive seven you could view that
as seven of these positive integer chips
so one two
three
four
five
six and seven and then negative six you
can represent that as six of these
negative integer chips
so we have negative one negative two
negative three negative four negative
five and negative six
now we can use the fact that every
positive integer if you have a positive
and a negative integer chip well
positive one plus negative one is going
to be equal to zero so they cancel out
so those cancel those also add up to
zero those also add up to zero those
also add up to zero those add up to zero
those add up to zero so you have a bunch
of zeros and then a positive one so all
you're left with is a positive one here
so that's going to be equal to one
let's do another example it's really
helpful to see these different scenarios
negative five plus five you might
already suspect what that is and pause
that video actually try to represent it
with integer chips
well negative five that's five of these
negative integer chips
so that's five right there and then
positive 5 would be 5 of the positive
integer chips one two three four five
and what's going to happen here well
those add up to zero those add up to
zero those add up to zero those add up
to zero those add up to zero so you're
just adding a bunch of zeros which is of
course going to give you a big zero
last but not least let's add three and
negative eight and let's represent that
again with integer chips
so positive three is one two three
positive integer chips negative eight is
let's see one two three four five six
seven eight of these negative integer
chips and
these cancel these cancel let me scratch
that out a little bit better those
cancel those cancel and those cancel so
you have zero plus zero plus zero plus
what do you have left over five of these
negative integer chips five negative
integer chips that's going to be equal
to negative five and we're done